Solo: A Star Wars Story has arrived in theaters,
and it finally answers all sorts of questions
fans have been asking for decades like how
Han and Chewie first met, how Han really won
the Millennium Falcon from Lando, and what
really happened during the infamous Kessel
Run.
But for every long-held Star Wars riddle the
film answered, it may have actually posed
even more new questions.
Here's a spoiler-filled look at the biggest
unanswered questions in Solo: A Star Wars
Story.
What's Qi'ra hiding?
When Han is finally reunited with his long-lost
love Qi'ra, it should be a joyous occasion.
But it isn't, because Qi'ra is clearly hiding
something or many things from her one-time
boyfriend.
The question is: what exactly is she hiding?
It's telling that when Han asks her how she
got out, she says she never did.
Between her comments about owing the Crimson
Dawn a major debt and Tobias Beckett's frequent
hints that Qi'ra has done unspeakable things,
it's clear there's a lot more to her story.
But until and unless we get a sequel, it seems
we'll just have to wonder exactly what Qi'ra
had to do to get off of Corellia that has
her so indebted to a guy like Darth Maul.
Speaking of which…
Wait, Darth Maul?!
Probably the most shocking moment in Solo
was the surprise reveal that Darth Maul is
the head honcho of the evil Crimson Dawn crime
syndicate.
Part of the reason it was such a surprise
is that the last time moviegoers saw Maul,
he had just been literally chopped in half
in 1999's The Phantom Menace.
Apparently, he got better, something fans
of the Star Wars cartoons already knew.
In Clone Wars and Rebels, it was established
that he used the force to survive his bisecting,
got some robot legs, and eventually ended
his life in a very brief and poorly thought
out attempt to get revenge on Obi-Wan Kenobi.
So what does Maul's appearance mean for any
possible Solo sequels?
Are we going to get to see a throwdown between
Maul and Han?
Is Qi-ra going to become Maul's apprentice?
We can't wait to find out!
What about the Wookiees?
After Chewbacca is rescued from slavery, he
explains in a heartbreaking sequence that
all the Wookiees were enslaved and driven
from their home world, and he's on a quest
to find them.
But when he does finally find some of his
fellow Wookiees, after helping them escape
from bondage he just… kinda leaves.
That opens up all sorts of questions.
Who exactly are these other Wookiees?
Fans had speculated that they might be his
wife Malla and his son Lumpy, first seen in
the 1978 Star Wars Holiday Special, but since
there are no subtitles, we don't actually
find out whether or not they're Chewie's family,
his tribe, or just some fuzzy randos.
Where do they go and what happens to them
when Chewbacca leaves?
Why does Chewie decide to stick with Han instead
of his people?
What role do the Wookiees play going forward?
We've got a lot of questions about the Wookiees.
But so far, only Chewie knows the answer and
if he's telling us, we sure don't understand
it.
"That's yes."
What happened to L3?
Arguably the biggest breakout character in
Solo is Lando's first mate, navigator, and
possible love interest L337 . So when L3 tragically
dies during the slave uprising she incited,
it's both moving and oddly triumphant.
And then they take part of her brain and upload
it into the Millennium Falcon, with Lando
declaring she's now part of the ship.
Sooo… that leaves us with a bunch of questions.
Does this mean L3 is actually in the Falcon
throughout the rest of the Star Wars series?
Is it possible that at some point between
Solo and A New Hope, Lando and the gang are
able to extract L3's consciousness from the
Falcon and give her a body again - maybe even
a human body in the form of Lando's cyborg
partner Lobot?
And considering her entire deal was trying
to free droids from subservience, isn't it
really unfortunate that she ends up just being
turned into a mindless tool?
Here's hoping we get L3 back somehow in the
future.
Did Enfys Nest start the rebellion?
At the end of Solo, Enfys Nest the leader
of the so-called outlaw gang that's been dogging
Tobias Beckett throughout the film tells Han
that she's going to use the millions of credits
from the stolen shipment of coaxium to fund
a rebellion to fight against the Empire.
This bombshell seems to suggest that Enfys
Nest is actually the founder of the Rebel
Alliance!
But if Enfys Nest did actually start the Rebellion,
what happened to her?
Could she somehow be related to Rey?
And if Han was in on the ground floor of creating
the Rebellion, how come this never came up
before - like when he later became a Rebel
General in Return of the Jedi?
Here's hoping we get to learn a lot more about
Enfys Nest in the future.
And speaking of the future...
Now what?
In April of 2018, Solo star Alden Ehrenreich
revealed that he was under contract for three
films.
And it seems clear that Solo is setting things
up for a trilogy or more.
With major plot threads around the Crimson
Dawn, Qi-ra, and Darth Maul left dangling,
not to mention the fate of L3, the Wookiees
and the birth of the Rebellion, Solo seems
prepared to fill in the gaps of everything
that happened between Revenge of the Sith
and A New Hope.
But will Solo actually get a sequel?
All of it comes down to how much money Solo
makes, meaning the answer to that question,
and all the rest, can actually be found right
now in your wallet.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!